c'est
merci c'est un grand honneur pour moi
pour l'ukraine et pour notre peuple
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
les élus de paris le peuple français
je suis reconnaissant d'avoir l'honneur
de m'adresser à vous aujourd'hui
je suis sûr que vous savez très bien ce
qui s'est passé du crâne vous savez
pourquoi cela s'est produit et vous
savez qui est coupable
et même ce qui est ce cas qui cache la
tête dans le sable
et c'est de trouver de l'argent en
russie
et je m'adresse à vous aux gens honnêtes
et rationnelle et audacieux
et je voudrais poser une question
comment arrêter cette guerre comment
instaurer la paix en ukraine parce que
la plupart des questions et des réponses
sont en commun dans nos mers mieux le 9
mars
les bombes aériennes russes ont été
lancés sur l'hôpital pour les enfants et
une maternité dans notre vie de mario
paul c'était une ville
paisible dans le sud est de l'ukraine
complètement paisible jusqu'à ce que les
troupes russes sont venus et l'ont pris
dans un siège brutal comme au moyen âge
ils ont commencé à tuer les les gens
dans cette maternité
sur lesquels le russe ont lancé les
bombes il avait des gens il y avait des
femmes qui se préparait à accoucher et
la plupart d'entre eux
ont survécu mais certaines ont été
gravement blessés
et une femme a pu et dû armes péter son
pied qui a été fracturée et une autre
femme avait en bassin fracturé et son
bébé est mort avant la naissance
la femme on a on essayait de sauver la
femme
elles demandaient les médecins de
laisser mourir de ne pas l'aider
elle ne vais pas dire et ne voyez pas
des raisons pour vivre
elle est morte en ukraine en europe en
quand des centaines de millions de
personnes ne peuvent pas penser que que
le monde pouvait être détruits
et je vous demande d'observer une minute
de silence à l'honneur à la mémoire des
milliers d'êtres aignan et ukrainienne
qui ont été tuées à la suite de
l'invasion russe du territoire ukrainien
merci merci
après les semaines novation russe
marie paule et d'autres villes
ukrainiennes frappé par l'occupant
rappelle les ruines de verdun
comme sur les photos de la première
guerre mondiale
que chacun et chacune
à vue a vu l'armée russe se ne distingue
pas les objets qu'elle cible ils
détruisent tous les quartiers
résidentiels les hôpitaux les écoles les
universités tôt il brûlait les entrepôts
de nourriture et de médicaments
ils brûlent tout
il ne prend pas en compte les concepts
de crimes de guerre
les causes obligations sur les
conventions et ils sont apportées la
terreur sur la seule kenya
et je crains de vous en est conscient
vous avez toutes les informations tout
est disponible tous les faits sur les
femmes violées par les militaires russes
dans les zones temporairement occupés
sur les réfugiés qui qu'elle tue sur les
routes sur les journalistes qu'il tube
sachant exactement que ce sont des
journalistes
sur les anciens qui ont survécu à
l'holocauste et sont maintenant obligés
de fuir dans les abris anti bandes des
frappes russe
l'europe
n'a pas vu depuis 80
ans dans l'europe l'a pas vu ce qui
s'est passé en ukraine
il y a des gens désespérés qui le
supplie de mourir
en 2019 quand je suis devenu président
il y avait des gens formant pour les
négociations avec la fédération de la
russie c'était un format normandie le
format des négociations qui devraient
mettre fin à la guerre dans le donbass
la guerre à l'est de l'ukraine et qui
dure depuis huit ans malheureusement
et quatre états ont participé au format
normandie l'ukraine la russie
l'allemagne et la france
4 mais il représentait tout le monde le
monde entier les positions du monde
entier toutes les positions
quelqu'un le soutenions quelqu'un a
essayé de retarder le processus ils
voulaient le perturber mais il semblait
important que le monde ait soit toujours
à cette table normandie
et quand il y avait des résultats des
négociations quand nous avons réussi à
libérer les gens de la captivité quand
nous avons pu négocier certaines
décisions en 2019 c'était une bouffée
d'air frais comme une leur d'espoir
l'espoir que le conversation avec le
récit peuvent était que les dirigeants
de la russie peuvent être persuadé par
les paroles que nous secoue
tout choisir la paix mais le 24 février
veille ou le jour qui a barré tous les
efforts
et même le concept du mundial up et
il a barré l'expérience européenne de
relations avec la russie elle est
décidée l'histoire en europe tout cela a
été bombardée par les troupes russes
écrasé par l'artillerie russe et brûlé
après les tirs de missiles russes
on n'a pas trouvé de vérité dans les
bureaux
et on est obligé de chercher la vérité
sur le champ de bataille
alors qu'est ce qui nous reste nos
valeurs l'unité et la détermination de
défendre notre liberté
notre liberté commune pour paris pour
kiev
pour berlin et varsovie pour madrid et
rome pour recel et bratislav
les bouffées d'air frais ne nous
aideront pas
nous devons agir ensemble de faire la
pression ensemble pour faire la russie a
cherché la peine mesdames et messieurs
le peuple français le 24 février
le peuple ukrainien s'est unie et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus ni de
représentant 3 n'y qui représentant de
gauche nous ne faisons pas attention à
ce qui est ce qui représentait le
pouvoir
et la coalition et l'opposition et on
pense de l'instauration de la paix
pour protéger notre pays nous sommes
reconnaissants à la france
que la france nous aide nous sommes très
reconnaissants pour les efforts du
président macro qui a fait preuve d'un
véritable leadership nous communiquons
constamment avec lui nous coordonnons
nos pas et les ukrainiens on voit que la
france apprécie également la vérité et
vous la protéger
vous vous savez ce que c'est la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
et chaque parole est important pour vous
je le sens et les ukrainiens le récente
et nous attendons de la france de votre
leadership
que vous puissiez faire en sorte que la
russie cherche la paix pour mettre fin à
cette guerre contre la liberté contre l
égalité contre la fraternité contre tout
skieur rendu l'europe unie et
libre et diverses nous attendons de la
france de votre leadership la
restauration de l'intégrité territoriale
de le prenne on peut le faire ensemble
et célia ceux qui ont des doutes entre
les personnes présentes alors je peux
vous dire que votre peuple est sûr comme
tous les autres peuples de l'europe
et pendant la présidence française de
l'union européenne
une décision
mûrie surprise sur l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne une
décision historique à un moment
historique
comme cela a toujours été le cas dans
l'histoire du peuple français
mesdames et messieurs le peuple français
demain ce sera au mois que les
ukrainiens se battent pour leur vie et
de leur liberté
que notre armée se pose de manière et je
ris et or et ori floride aux forces
supérieures de la russie
nous avons besoin d'eux dad encore plus
des deux plus de soutien pour que la
liberté ne parle pas elle doit être bien
armé les chars les armes antichars les
avions de combat la défense et riant
vous pouvez nous aider nous en avons
besoin vous pouvez pour que la liberté
ne tarde pas le monde doit le soutenir
avec des sanctions contre l'agresseur
chaque semaine on ne vont pas cas de
sanction les entreprises françaises
doivent quitter le marché russe revenons
au chant leroy merlin et autres doivent
cesser d'être les sponsors de la machine
de guerre de la russie
ils doivent arrêter de financer le
meurtre et enfants et deux femmes le
viol
tout le monde va se rappeler que les
valeurs
valent plus que les bénéfices
et nous devons déjà pensé de l'avenir de
la façon dont nous allons vivre après la
guerre il faut des garanties et des
garanties sur que la sécurité sera
inébranlable et que les gars ne seront
plus possibles dans ce monde
nous créons ce système de garantie aux
nouveaux systèmes de sécurité
ou la france aura un rôle de premier
plan pour que personne
ne ferait jamais en pleurer la mort pour
que les gens vivent leur lit
et pour qu'on dise à dio pas sous les
bombes pas en état de guerre
mais quand l'heure via
avec la dignité parce que nous devons
vivre pour être respectées
pour contexte de revoir
comme la france c'est à dire au revoir à
belmondo
merci la france une gloire à l'ukraine
représentation nationale je vous
remercie de vous être adressée aux
parlementaires monsieur au peuple
français la séance se devait
[Musique]